The next thing I'm doing here then is I'm
using a function that I wrote here in this
code called is_street_name, okay. And the way
is_street_name works is it simply looks at the element
that was passed in so in this case, I'm
taking that nested tag that I got back from my
way element, alright? And I'm checking the k attribute
for that element okay, and if you remember how attributes
are part of a tag, okay. So for example, here is an example of
a k attribute and in fact, what I'm doing next then is, I'm saying all right, I
want that k attribute to actually have this
value. Okay. So I'm looking for tags that
actually specify a street name. Again we're talking
about a way here. Okay. So items with
this particular key should have as their value,
the name for that way, whether it's 3rd Street
or 14th Avenue or say, 7th Avenue here
in New York City, near where the MongoDB offices
are located, okay. So the next thing I'm doing here then is if I've got a tag
that's actually specifying the name for that particular way,
then I'm going to call audit_street_type, okay.
So let's take a look at that. All right. Now,
the way I've set up audit_street_type is it's actually
going to use a regular expression. This regular expression is
one that we've seen before. What it does is it pulls
out or matches the very last word in a street
name, because most street names end with the street type that
we're interested in. So avenue or boulevard street, something along those
lines, okay? So, in order to get the value that actually
matched, so if this condition is true, then there was a
match of some kind, and the way I get the specific match
is by calling the group method of the matched object, okay?
So the next step here then is what I'm doing is, I
don't actually want to see these come out in my audit.
These are what I expect as names. These are normal, there's nothing
wrong with these. I don't care about these, I don't care about
trying to fix these. I'm just trying to find weirdos here, okay.
So what I want to do here is, if the street type that I matched okay, as the
last word in the street name, okay, is not in my expected list. Then what I
want to do is to my street_types
dictionary, which I initialized right here, what I want
to do is add that street name. So
basically what this says is, if the street type
that I found here for this particular tag is a
weirdo, then I want to add it to the street_types
dictionary where I'm keeping track of all the unusual street
types. Okay now the way I've done this is I've set
this up as a default dictionary, okay, and this allows
me to not have to check to see whether the key
is already in the dictionary it's a convenience. Okay, read the
docs if you want to know a little bit more about
default dictionaries. The value for each one of these
keys, so, if I find something unusual like "ave." okay
for example, which isn't going to be in this
expected set, that key might appear in street_types. The value
then, will be a set. So what I'm going
to do then is for my street type, I'm going
to add the specific street name that I found,
because I'd like to see all of the examples, alright,
where a particular unusual street type was used to give
me a better sense for the data as a whole.